hello everyone uh my name is money young
and i would like to welcome you all to
pi data global 2021 today we have a
speaker here um his name is eric ma and
he'll be talking about an attempt to
demystify graph deep learning um eric is
a principal data scientist at um moderna
and actually
yeah i think that's as well destroyed
and stuff so that he just goes straight
into his car because the buyer is a
little bit lensy um please if you have
any questions you can make use of the q
and a session and i would think audrey's
hand is over to you um eric
okay thank you very much manny um
so hi everybody i'm eric uh like four
years ago at
pi data i would like to do an attempt at
demystifying graph deep learning so
yeah like i said four years ago i did a
talk at pi data
in nyc and i tried to demystify bayesian
deep learning and four years later here
i am trying to demystify graph deep
learning for those of you who want to
follow follow along on the slides at
your own pace i've actually put the
slides in the chat so please feel free
to go ahead
oh sorry it's to i would like to paste
it for everyone please feel free to
follow along on the slides uh on on your
own pace if you find me boring i i am
completely unoffended if you do so
so
just to briefly introduce myself a
little bit uh as manum said i currently
work as a principal data scientist at
modern therapeutics yes this is the
moderna that is one of the two companies
that have successfully brought a covet
19 vaccine
onto the market we're on a mission to
make mrna medicines and leverage the
power of mrna to to do some really cool
stuff to make therapeutics for people
who need them and
the team that i'm on we're hiring like
crazy right now i'd be happy to talk
about jobs and positions and potential
opportunities uh that might be showing
up in the near future
uh prior to that i was at the novartis
institutes for biomedical research
likewise over there i did a lot of
enzyme engineering data science work as
well as chem informatics related uh data
science work
mostly in the realm of like machine
learning systems but there were also
really cool
cool novel models that i got to explore
with colleagues and stuff and so that
was really awesome to see
and prior to that i was in the
department of biological engineering at
mit where i did my thesis on influenza
research and one of the fun facts is i
actually joined moderna because there
was an opportunity to go back into the
influenza world which was my
professional history for a good chunk of
time
i'm really glad to be back in that world
again
um i think part of my own mantra at work
has been to accelerate science to the
speed of thought that is where my
headspace lives professionally has lived
for the past five years thus far and
then my toolkit it's usually deep
learning bayesian stats and network
science um but uh and i partner up with
colleagues who work at the bench who do
imaging work and all sorts of nlp kind
of work as well to really try to
accelerate science make science go as
fast as the human can think about new
ideas
okay so let's get into the motivation
for this talk
how many if if you've heard of this guy
fair enough i hope i'm pronouncing his
name correct um he's got this tweet from
four years ago which is basically um
which basically reflects my sentiment
around the world of
all of these deep learning
explainers and blog posts it's it's
way too math heavy for my taste
part of the reason is because after
x many years of trying to learn deep
learning on my own i realized that my
hack has always been to learn deep learn
deep learn the math of deep learning by
programming and by drawing pictures and
not by staring at equations so
i am out to solve point number four on
in this talk where are all the pretty
pictures that explain the math behind
these complicated concepts
okay so this is a talk on graph deep
learning which means that we probably
have to take a step back and start by
asking what are graphs right so let's
talk about that
when we when you think of graphs i want
you to think of networks of all kind
that you can see inside your daily lives
we know that there are social networks
like twitter and linkedin we know that
there are flight networks between
airports we know that there are
transportation networks there are road
networks between cities
any kind of network that you can think
of should be your anchoring example for
what graphs are
so what are graphs then graphs are
actually comprised of two collections of
things
graphs are comprised of nodes and edges
nodes are those red dots that you see on
this chart on this diagram over here and
edges are the yellow lines that you can
see over here
so
red dots are the nodes they are entities
that you can count things that you can
enumerate all right things that you know
are
uh not abstract ideas but actually like
real things that you can you can you can
count feel etc so people in a social
network would be one example airports in
a flight network are another example
and then there are things like the edges
which actually are the relations between
these countable things right so in a
social network you would connect people
based on whether they were
uh they were professionally acquainted
or not or
whether they are friends in real life in
a flight network you would connect
airports
according to whether there is a flight
path between them or not all right
so
really when you think of networks when
you when you think of graphs i want you
to think about networks
now herein lies the problem
everything about deep learning
operates on a raise
these guys here they don't look like a
raise
so that begs the question
if we have this thing called graph deep
learning how exactly do we represent
graphs as arrays
so that is the first thing that we're
going to going to explore
i'm going to pull out an example from my
professional life that i've always gone
back to as a minimally complex anchoring
example it's got a bit of chemistry
inside there if you've taken high school
chemistry you'll totally get what we're
talking about here
here's a molecule it's an organic
molecule
actually the fact that it's organic is
not really important itself right
the more important thing is that it's
got nodes and edges what are the nodes
in this graph the nodes in this
molecular graph are the atoms and the
edges in this molecular graph are the
bonds between those atoms okay so that's
a molecule represented as a graph
now here are the s here is the exact
same molecule with numerical properties
annotated on each of the nodes all right
so let's say we decide to go in and
annotate
every single atom in the graph with the
atomic mass and the valence number of
valence electrons that it has
the atomic mass being basically uh sorry
the atomic number being the number of
protein protons that that atom has and
the valence number being the number of
electrons that are present in its outer
shell of
its electron shells
so
carbon has six protons and four
electrons in its outer shell hydrogen
has one proton and one
electron in its outer shell oxygen has
eight protons and only two
uh oh sorry two possible bonds i got the
definition of valence wrong it's
actually the number of bonds that it can
it can form so it has two uh
possible bonds that it can form as a
result of uh two valence electrons
um and so this is how you would
represent the same molecule with
numerical properties
and now what you can do to
obtain a complete picture of the
numerical properties of all the nodes is
take all of these vectors over here and
stack them up on the right
here the order
might matter and it will matter when you
think about the coming operations that
are going to show up later on but for
now take me at my word that
if you take if you uh in order to obtain
the node what we call the node feature
matrix which is a complete picture of
the numerical properties of each of
these nodes you order them you order you
stack all of these up in a particular
order that you get to determine together
beforehand and you get back what we
would call a node feature matrix all
right
so we now know how to represent nodes as
arrays and as jim sheldon has
noted inside the chat you actually have
another way
that is
a very useful tool for representing the
edges as an array
so let's take a look at what we call the
adjacency matrix the adjacency matrix
essentially lets us represent edges in a
graph
and in this particular adjacency matrix
that we're showing over here
it shows ones anywhere that an edge
exists between a pair of nodes
and it shows an empty entry where
everywhere else don't worry jim it's all
good i appreciate the engagement i
really really love that so
adjacency matrix this particular
adjacency matrix is what we would call a
binary adjacency matrix it's one if you
have an edge and zero if you don't
note that this adjacency matrix is
actually symmetric because the graph is
undirected
here's an alternative adjacency matrix
that you could show right this is
another adjacency matrix that shows the
number of bonds between atoms all right
so most of these
edges are single bonds but there is one
over here between atom number two and
atom number six that has two bonds in
between them and so the corresponding
entry in the adjacency matrix has the
value of 2.
okay
so let's
take a step back and
summarize this section thus far
we have graphs we want to be able to put
graphs inside a neural net model so we
need the array representation
the array representation of a graph
comes in two forms and you actually need
both forms together you need the node
feature matrix to represent nodes and
you need the edge adjacency matrix to
represent edges and these two together
give a complete numerical representation
of the graph
so now
we need to talk about another pretty
elementary
graph
a
math operation called message passing
message passing on graphs that's the
next thing that we need to explore
before we can build our intuition about
what
graph neural networks are so i'd like
you to focus your attention first to the
left hand side of this figure
over here you will see a chain graph
this graph this chain graph has four
nodes it starts from
node one all the way to node four over
there okay
i've cloned in this figure the chain
graph to represent things that are
happening over time so let's focus our
attention on the top left hand corner
first
we might have a message that exists on
one of these nodes at a particular
moment in time and that's represented by
the blue dot on top of that particular
node
okay
so what
we do in mess the goal of message
passing is to take that blue dot and
move it along the graph according to
where the edges point towards okay and
if
and and if you do that over a number of
time steps over here as we're showing
over here as you go from time step one
to time step two the blue dot will pass
from node number one to node number two
based on the arrows that are that that
is between node one and two all right if
you do that again it goes from two to
three three to four very intuitive stuff
let's take a look at message the
placement of the message on the graph
that actually has a has an array
representation as well and it looks
something like this guy over here you
have a vector
that has a one where the message is and
zero everywhere else
you also have the adjacency matrix which
by the way stays the same all throughout
the entire message passing operation
i'm going to put it to you that if you
try to simulate this on your in in numpy
on your own message pass when you do the
dot product between this message vector
and the adjacency directed adjacency
matrix that shows up over here you will
be able to accurately simulate the
progress of the message from the first
node to the second node to the third
node to the fourth node and then finally
off into oblivion because there's
nowhere to pass the message
using nothing more than linear algebra
operations for those of you who are
astute and looking at the matrix matrix
multiply on the right and going like
that can't possibly work you've got to
transpose something over there you are
absolutely right i've structured this
vector as a vertical vector column
vector and not a row vector simply for
convenience and spacing i don't have
enough space to draw a horizontal vector
so please ignore the fact that a
transpose is absolutely necessary to
make this work now if you
reverse the reverse the you if you did a
bunch of other transposes and reverse
the order of operations you'd actually
get the adjacency matrix dot product the
feature matrix which is the kind of
convention that i'll be using the rest
of the slides but this was an
illustration that needed enough space on
my ipad when i was drawing it
so i'm going to
going to just put this to you that
message passing on grass again is
nothing more than a dot product of
matrices and that's shown in this like
little simple uh python function that is
on my on my slides over here
okay so let's look at message passing in
the context of our minimally minimally
complex example to see how message
passing works and for this i'm going to
have you focus on the bottom right hand
corner of this molecule over here where
we have the carbon oxygen and hydrogen
those three uh those three atoms will
sort of be our focal point for this this
this part
so notice how we have the vector 6 4 8 2
and 1 1 on these three nodes
respectively
when we do message passing
the whole idea
is we take our neighbors values and we
pass them into ourselves
they get passed into ourselves and we
sort of sum them up that is the most
elementary message passing operation
that you can do
on this particular graph so the result
of that would be you take 6 and you add
1 and that becomes the
value 7 over here you take four and you
add one and that becomes the value five
in the message past uh message passing
result
same goes for this hydrogen right this
hydrogen has the value eight uh takes
its value eight and two from its
neighbor neighboring oxygen
right and so that after one round of
message passing you get an 8 2 vector on
the hydrogen and then for this carbon
well it's got summations from this
carbon oxygen and other oxygen and trust
me the math works out you get something
that is 22
comma 8 for that vector over there and
i'll put it to you keep this notation in
mind there that this is an adjacency
matrix dot product the feature matrix to
give you exactly this result
okay
so now how do we connect message passing
neural networks to message passing to
neural networks so let's talk about that
i've decided to move away now from
drawing graphs over and over and over
because that's going to get really
really really really tedious so we're
going to do a bit of abstraction over
here we've got the adjacency matrix and
the node feature matrix and we can
define math operations that are
basically like python functions a
message passing operation that accepts
an adjacency matrix and a node feature
matrix gets you the message passed
matrix
now here's where the neural net stuff
happens you can actually take a feed
layer that operates on
graph uh the output of the graph um
output of the message passing operation
and
return uh pass it through and pass it
sorry you can pass that thing that said
matrix through a feed forward neural net
where you have learnable parameters to
return
uh
a
neural net transformed version of the
message passed matrix right and there
are learnable params inside here which
means this uh node level this is what we
would call a node level embedding of our
uh or sorry learned embedding of our uh
uh
of our original graph
uh and and that is basically the kind of
way that you you connect message passing
with neural nets it's literally nothing
more than this at its core
if you are doing neural net
models that operate on predicting a
single number per graph
sometimes you might need an operation to
summarize all of the graph nodes into a
single vector so you get a graph level
vector rather than a per node vector and
so you can do a summation operation
which sums across nodes and gives you
back a single vector for that for that
graph
um forgot to mention by the way
summation is not the only operation you
can do you can do a mean you can do
anything else that reduces the dimension
by one collapses the node dimension
basically so
there is research that goes that is
being conducted on basically what what
operation would be considered say
mathematically injective such that you
get a one-to-one mapping from graph to
uh the vector that you have that that is
that is resultant from there
and so if we were to connect everything
together you would actually get this
schematic diagram right you you start
with your graph data on the left hand
side you can do message passing plus
feed forward operations which give you
the result of message passing and some
non-linearity non-linear transforms
inside there and then you can pass it
through again a graph summary
operation to get a graph level summary
vector if you are doing a graph property
prediction
per se and then pass that through yet
another neural net operation to get the
output that you're interested in and
that
is graph deep learning demystified
but that's not the end
let me show you as a little bit of bonus
some code right actually if this is
probably better read on your own let me
see if i can zoom in a little bit so
the code basically looks something like
that you can define a message passing
operation that accepts graph data
you can define a graph summary operation
that returns that particular thing over
there you can do a graph neural net feed
forward operation as well
purely in numpy code
you can do feed forward
operations define a feed forward
operation like that and if you define a
mathemati a python model
your what you might the code that you
might write actually looks something
like that so i'll leave this there for
you to browse on your own
on the slides think about it ponder
about it
and sort of get a flavor for what what
exactly is happening behind the scenes
when you're thinking about graph neural
net operations
here is a bonus fact by the way
if you take
convolutions they actually look a lot
like message passing
so let's look at convolutions on images
all right we start with a pixel grid
that looks something like that in blue
and we have a convolutional filter in
red that looks something like this it's
got ones on the outside and zero on the
inside
if you do the convolution operation with
certain padding and border settings then
you will get this particular array as a
result okay
so far so good all with me so far if you
think about pixels on a grid
pixels are entities and they share a
spatial relation with their neighbors
which means they can be represented as a
graph which actually means you can take
each of these pixels represent them as a
node on a lattice grid lattice grid
and draw edges between any pair of nodes
that are neighboring to one another and
if you do a simple message passing
operation on this grid over here you
will get the exact same result as a
convolution with that particular
with that particular filter so i put it
to you there are some really really cool
connections between these two ideas
really fun stuff
so when do we use graph neural nets well
that actually exposes a deeper question
which is when do we use what types of
neural nets and i really want to
start a discussion maybe even hammer
home some points over here
partly because i've reviewed machine
learning papers in which the authors
used convolutional neural networks on
tabular data which made zero sense it
was not principled at all and i wrote
that in the review
and it was
it was very very surprising that they
did that the only motivation that i
could think of for them trying that was
the authors were just enamored with
neural nets and wanted to have an excuse
to try cnns
so
when do we use what types of neural nets
well basically looks like this
you have to think about the inductive
biases that you're trying to encode in
your model
feed forward neural nets
encode the bias of interactions between
features
convolutional neural nets
encode the inductive bias of spatial
correlations
sequential models which are recurrent
and auto-regressive models
encode the inductive bias of temporal or
sequential dependencies and graph neural
nets
encode the bias of relational data all
right wherever you have relational
information graph neural nets are an
appropriate model otherwise not really
alright so here's the summary
graphs can be represented as matrices
you have the node feature matrix as well
as the adjacency matrix you need both of
these matrices in order to be able to
represent numerically represent a graph
we can't do without either of them
also graph deep learning is essentially
anchored on message passing if you know
message passing you know the basics of
graph deep learning
with that i'm going to leave you with
some resources to learn more you can
click on you can click on any of these
links there are some really good ones i
particularly like the gentle
introduction to graph neural networks
which came after my ask my essay this
one's on distill.pub it's by some
friends of mine at google really really
cool stuff
so that's that's a really good resource
to learn even more about this about this
field
and with that i'd like to thank you for
your time and i'm happy to answer
questions
thank you very much eric for your turn
um
i think if you move over to the question
session we'll be able to see two
questions actually
yeah i'd definitely love to thank them
now yeah definitely definitely so uh
alexander has two questions um
i will answer live the first one uh the
easier one first so
let me go back here the slides are
available up here at this link one more
time i'm going to copy them into the
chat so that everybody has
access to it
so
send the chat to everyone
all right so that's
that's the easiest question of them all
answered
so then alex's alexander's second
question was in our example we showed
implicitly a supervised scenario
how about unsupervised learning
scenarios such as using contrastive
losses what are your thoughts my
thoughts are totally doable
if you think about what the structure of
a supervised machine learning model is
in classical statistical terms what
you've got is a fancy link function
between your input and output all right
now if you think about what you're
trying to do in an unsupervised setting
there is actually this really cool
connection to probabilistic modeling
where you're trying to learn the
structure of your data based on some
form of likelihood and inside there
if you're thinking about mixture models
which is again my
anchoring example for unsupervised
learning scenarios
you can if you can write a likelihood
for your mixture model based on your
data you can use gnns as the fancy link
function to give you your likelihood
calculation it literally is that
um happy to talk more offline i think
this one is a is a big big big
this one's a fairly big question to go
deep into so happy to talk live talk
more uh
later on but basically the idea here is
uh
just as you know how you can use feed
forward layers and convolutional layers
in an unsupervised setting think of
graph neural net layers in exactly the
same mold as those guys and if you
really want to broaden the way that you
think about these layers they are fancy
link functions like the logistic
function all right so that's sort of my
perspective on uh
on this on this over here
so that's my answer that question has
been answered live
uh severin has a question so gnn it's
just a custom and an architecture and
the answer is yeah
but one that does have a few uh api
design implications right like you
notice you can't you're not just
accepting one vector of data you're
accepting actually two vectors of data
right so yeah that's uh that is
something that you would probably need
to keep in mind if you're designing an
api for graph neural nets
and then uh lewis has the question uh
what inductive biases are encoded
in non-auto-regressive graph
transformers lewis i'm not going to
i don't wish to buy uh to butcher
uh the the answer to this question so
let's take this offline partially
because i actually don't really know
much about non-auto-regressive graph
transformers i'm familiar with
transformers i just have not seen
the underlying implementation of
non-auto-regressive graph transformers
so i'd really love to explore that in
maybe a different setting so
i'm sorry i can't i don't want to answer
that question at this point but it's
because i i don't have enough knowledge
to answer it publicly and i don't want
to give you anything incorrect
okay and then we have some other
questions that are showing up inside the
chat
let me just see here
um
can i share my contact info for future
questions they uh my contact info is on
my personal website so if you just go to
the base url of that
website you'll find the contact page
over there
what in sarunas has another question
which is
probably the last question i'll answer
[Music]
oh actually that one's a bit of a
complicated question i'm going to skip
over to shikhalam's question which is
what dl framework are usually using for
graph neural nets
i've actually used jacks and stacks and
then implemented custom layers on my own
for message passing but if you don't
want to do that you can actually use
jraf
if you're in the jacks land and i think
there's pytorch geometric if you're
inside the pie torch land
i really like jax by the way even though
i don't get to use it at work
jax has all these wonderful wonderful
ideas on the most idiomatic array api
ever so
uh i definitely like like jax a lot more
cool uh
manny i think we're at the end of time
is that correct
yes please we uh just wanted to just let
you know and also please those of us who
have more questions we can also move
that um to the slack group and also to
gather the data town as well thank you
very much for your talk um eric i mean
it was actually great listening to the
talk and i also want to thank everyone
for taking their time to listen to his
talk as well um i think ness on the
agenda will be having a break so i'll be
stopping the recording now and thank you
everyone once again
thank you very much manny